in this world even the most mundane
daily life can be brought to a sudden
violent end here in Hassan this week
these people were waiting for a bus when
the Russian missiles hit killing six
it was just one of at least 158 attacks
on civilians verified in the last week
alone by Sky News
garages Sports Halls nurseries farm
buildings were all hit
29 people died and 55 were wounded a
fairly typical week in a stage of the
war where the civilian death toll keeps
a steady rhythm
darker Hina is a journalist based in
Kiev
well I'll re-kill now or later or
something so you think about death every
day
the UN Human Rights office has confirmed
that at least 8 000 civilians have been
killed since Russia invaded more than 13
000 injured although the UN warned the
true number is likely to be
substantially higher over the course of
a year that means on average 22
civilians were killed each day and 36
were injured
these are the civilian casualties
throughout the war the early days were
the worst but every month brings deaths
and injuries and the front line covers
the entire country the bigger the circle
here the higher the death toll it is
highest in the east in cities like
battered mariupo but even a small
pinprick in the map like this a small
city called Venezia 26 people have died
oliviv just a few hours from the border
with Poland the death toll is nine I try
not to get too used to it because it's
not normal at all and it's really like a
domestic terrorism you know because you
cannot plan anything you cannot plan
your work day your time with your
friends because you depend on the sirens
you know uh of course lots of ukrainians
just ignore them and take a risk
for an entire year this is how the
citizens of Ukraine have lived none of
them ever far away from death
Tom Cheshire Sky News